the companies you're involved with now
are isn't it like quite a few
and a lot of that is to use business
solutions to really help real world
issues
it's not thought out that way business
opportunities approach me maybe a dozen
a day sometimes at least one every day
will you join me we join our company
will you be on our board of advisors
whatever they want my name and
i i'm only one person i don't have a
staff i don't have i don't have money i
gave that away a long time ago and i
just have to it's bothers me the number
of times i have to say no then they
still come back again you have to say no
more
and hide from them a little um
so
that's i get hit a lot once in a while
you know i used to meet people more
often maybe once a week i'd go out to a
lunch and hear what they're up and just
say that's really sounds good you know
i'm not a part of it i don't want to get
into anything new i have a busy life and
then one time i sat down and they
started talking about solid state disks
do you all know what solid state disks
are
they're they're chips and they're faster
than the hard disk that were made of
atoms spinning around they use electrons
in the solid state disks and everybody
was starting to talk about it and this
one company they had instead of building
a solid-state disk that you connect
where it disconnects
they had a board that plugs right into
the slots in the computer you're getting
about the eight slots in the application
plugs right into the slot in the
computer
and then has software
that makes it perform like a disk
and because of that you can write better
software that makes it have more data
and run faster than all these other
approaches to disk drives that have to
use a standard connector that goes at a
certain standard speed
and this company had designed things the
way i thought as a designer when i
designed stuff for apple
and i was offered a chance to join them
and i said yes
that was fusion io they went big and
successful as fast and important as
apple when they did they changed the
whole world they were just starting you
know you're starting out and a you know
a one gigabyte
a solid state disk at first cost twenty
thousand dollars wow you know we're up
to terabytes now for hundreds of dollars
in solid state disc one terabyte for 170
bucks today i mean
um
so i that was a great company i was so
glad to be a part of that because they
were changing the world yeah yeah and i
didn't really make a lot from it the
founders made you know a couple hundred
million each but then they each divorced
their mormon wives of salt lake city and
but i didn't think these mormons with
their type families that i would have
dinners with that would ever you know be
in that divorce category
so that was fusion io now more recently
there was a group that approached me
and what they do is they look at ways
you can make
electricity costs more efficient go into
a big company a big factory and change
lights and change air conditioners and
and do other things and make it use less
electricity
and then they would collect a portion of
the savings but they would have to
finance it themselves they'd have to go
in do all the installations of the
materials and they became they were
making tens and hundreds of millions of
dollars a year for like six years this
is an ongoing successful company that
has a formula they're real people and
crypto was starting up
and i talked to them for two years it
took them to talk me into joining them
as i liked what they did but we what we
what they made they made it really
interesting we're going to have a crypto
coin on an exchange they wound up naming
it was x
and it's on exchange in malta and a
couple other places and then people can
buy in and the blockchain tracks
everything from turning on a light
switch to all the costs involved in the
savings and you get part of the savings
right in the blockchain you is the
investor in it
and that's called force
e-f-f-o-r-c-e and i really love what uh
what's what it's all about it's all
about energy efficiency i was about that
my whole life yeah and then we got the
space company uh started by a really
good friend of mine that he always has
business thinking so far beyond me and
thinking about all the sub markets and
who you can approach for things and
raising money uh has done incredible
with this last company ripcord they're
going to go public next year probably
you know for a couple of trillion i
don't know i sold this ft at one point
and people were getting mad at me they
were barking at me about energy being
wasted with nft
so is this energy saving solution well
even bitcoin you know gold of all it's
only mathematical no human can control
bitcoin and the amounts of it and
everything
that's um it takes a lot of a lot of
energy to mine it to create to keep
bitcoin to keep these all the cyber
currencies and nfts going um
but it costs amount of energy for
whatever anything is worth right because
the costs the economy
three e's the economy equals the energy
used equals the emissions mean pollution
okay and that's a formula never here
anywhere else sounds as easy as as um
equals mc squared for einstein right
it's that easy
the global economy gnp say
equals the amount of energy that was
used if you double one you double the
other
and that equals the amount of pollution
that we get
double the energy will double the
pollution the only the only way to to
really solve this uh
climate problem is
take our lives way way back down in
economy
take them way back down so i don't buy
into a lot of you know people thinking
let's do this one little step you know
buy an electric car or get a solar panel
that it actually makes any difference at
all it can actually go the opposite way
just like the bitcoin mining but you
know everything we got in life um a
house a car this rv is beautiful
do you think the world's
going towards crypto or you think we'll
always stick with fiat currency
it's hard to erase things that humans
have learned and can put into books
methods of doing it some countries have
even disallowed crypto on blockchain
technologies it can be used a lot i
think it's being used a lot these days
to rip people off
i'll start a crypto i'll hire an
engineer that knows how to create it and
i'll get a celebrity to back it up you
know and we'll put out the um
the kim coin kim kardashian or something
like that that's probably a bad example
but um it's a great example it's a great
example it is it's a really good one
okay because i don't do social websites
i don't really
how know the names to use but we'll call
and i see that happening all the time
and then the founders that started it
pull off some millions of dollars right
away from investors that say i want to
get in quick and early when it's young
because it's going to grow like bitcoin
i'll make a billion out of out of
pennies
and they jump in and then it goes to
zero that's the common story it's not
the only story there's some others that
have made it for a while for
some good reasons yeah so i'm kind of
nfts fall into that category too the
number of people getting ripped off on
crypto and nfts is just just outrageous
now bitcoin is safe because it's the big
elephant on the block it's stable right
like conservative conservative thinking
you go for the big ones and they'll be
around and um
yeah bitcoin is uh this is you uh stable
so i don't invest
i don't i have never invested in stock
in my life i've never used apple stock
app on the iphone ever because why
it goes to my happiness formula i found
that my head gets to a peaceful spot
where it's not worrying about everything
being up and down up and down up and
down like day traders i had traders
around me and i watched what they went
through and i just turned the other way
i don't read any financial papers i
don't want to be
you know i don't want that to affect my
life so i never invested in stocks um
bitcoin i bought a bunch of bitcoin at
the start to say how do you play with
this new thing how do you buy something
online and i conquered that and how do
you buy things in other countries
and how would you even pay for like a
donut in another country how can you
find an atm that works on your bitcoin
and i wanted to experiment and learn it
all
and then bitcoin went way up well i got
scared and i sold all my bitcoin except
one bitcoin i had that's not my purpose
is to have enough to play with and
experiment with but not to make money on
and two times it's gone way up and made
money and just recently i think bitcoin
is gonna go to a hundred thousand i just
you know i don't know where you get that
feeling i can't put any uh mathematics
to it i just really feel it from all of
the interest the interest in crypto is
so high and so i
put a put a bunch of money into uh
um
into
an online wallet account coinbase
and pretty much it's sitting right where
it was right now went way up it doubled
and then it halved again and
you know
that's but that's not my way in life i'm
just that's not important to me
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]
you